Welcome to section two.
R is a powerful tool
for data analysis.
And the first step to working
with data in R is to get the
data into R.
Suppose I have a CSV file on
my computer and I wanted to
load it into R. Since I'm
running R on OS X, I could use
the Command-D trick to change
my working directory to the
folder with the file.
But it's also helpful to know
how to navigate using the
getwd and setwd functions.
We'll also make use of the List
Files function, which
lists the files and folders in
the current working directory.
I want to get into my Google
Drive folder so I'm going to
specify that in the
setwd function.
Next, I'm going to print out
the folders in this Google
Drive folder and navigate
to Projects.
Next, I'm going to navigate
to the Top_Secret folder.
And since I know there's a data
folder there, I'm just
going to add this folder
into my setwd command.
All right.
I've arrived, and I can now see
the data set of interests
in my current working
directory, the
state.csv data set.
Since I'll be saving this code,
I might as well save my
current working directory
in a setwd command at
the top of my script.
This way, I won't need to set
the directory in the future
unless I change the working
directory of my project files.
Now that I'm ready to go, I'll
load in the state.csv file
using the read.csv function,
specifying the name of the
file in quotation marks.
When you're reading the CSV file
into R, it's stored as a
data matrix, which is more
formally called a data frame
in R.
Just like with a regular matrix,
I can use the dim
function to see how many
rows and columns
are in the data set.
There are 51 rows representing
all US states and Washington,
DC and 12 different columns
representing the 12 different
variables recorded
for each state.
I'll use the head function to
print out the first two rows
of this state data set
just like I could do
with a regular matrix.
However, if I apply the length
function, R will just return
the number of variables in
the data set, which are
represented by the columns.
Data frames are one of the
most common objects for
holding data inside of R, and
I can subset on them in ways
similar to how I might
subset a matrix.
This is fine, but there
are actually better
ways with data frames.
A new function for data frames
worth remembering is the names
function which is used to access
the variable names.
Once you know the names of the
variables, it's easy to
extract out the entire
variable using
the data set name.
Followed by a dollar sign,
then followed by
the variable name.
Let's take a look at
the smoke variable.
The smoke variable is
a numerical variable
representing the percentage
of people who
smoke in each state.
If I wanted, I could apply some
standard functions like
the mean or standard deviation
function to get some summary
information about
this variable.
In addition to subsetting with
brackets, I can make use of
this subset function.
Here I'm going to examine only
states with smoking rates
higher than 25%.
If I wanted, I could also
specify that I only want to
select a small number
of columns.
Next, I'll take a look at the
party that won each state in
the 2012 presidential
election.
This is in the pres12
variable.
Note that the pres12 variable
isn't numerical, yet it was
stored for the smoke variable
which was a numerical object
in the state data frame.
Data frames can hold a different
type of variable in
each column while a matrix can
only hold a single data type
for the entire matrix.
Notice also that the output
doesn't look like a regular
string output, which generally
has quotation marks when it is
printed out.
Additionally, there's a listing
at the bottom that
indicates there are
two levels.
Output like this indicates that
this is a factor variable
or a factor object.
A factor object is a special
kind of object that's sort of
a blend between character
and numerical variables.
If you ever have substantial
trouble working with factors
in R, you can just convert the
factor to a string with the
as.character function.
R will generally convert a
character variable back into a
factor variable when it is
appropriate to do so.
However, when R does do this
conversion, it may notify you
with a warning.
Just read your warnings
carefully and make sure that
that's all that's happening.
In the next video, we'll talk
about ways to take a quick
look at a data object inside
of R, and we'll also take a
look at date objects.